when the um
software license if this cloud provider
provides for the service they must have
a license for it because you're not
allowed to install it on a computer
without a license are you
yeah most vendors have got bulk licenses
you'll find any large organization
will have a deal so for example um
google provide
microsoft platforms they'll have a
massive bug deal with microsoft where
they just can have any number of
installations they just pay them so much
yeah it does make sense of big companies
they don't want to have to worry about
individual licenses they'll just say
we're going to have something in the
order of several thousand several
hundred and now just microsoft would say
okay this is how much it's going to cost
you that's it
i would say one thing about um
the google cloud platform the user
interface that we use through the web
page has a habit of changing
um
my friend and colleague randy
who we collaborate on this course um i
was asking him today how to delete a
project on the google com
computer engine and um
he said oh the ui changed two days ago
i'm not sure so we both have to search
for it so do expect the ui to change
somewhat and google has a command line
api which doesn't change but the the web
page does tend to change
okay good question on docker today's
lesson is basically about dockers i'll
be talking a lot about docker over the
next four hours okay so it'll be more
than an overview you get
okay so any other questions before i
move on
okay we're good to go then
so what we're going to do now lesson two
it's on virtualization and lightweight
containers
and so we're looking at the whole
concepts of virtualization but most
importantly we're going to look at
lightweight containers and in particular
docker is one of the major
implementations of lightweight
containers not the only one
but um docker seems to have been got
themselves into a nice position in the
market
so let's um where's my mask on
because i've got three screens here i'm
never quite sure
where the mouse is
right
so what we're going to do is look at the
principles of virtualization what is
this all about
then we're going to look at how linux
supports virtualization which is
actually very important this has been
the enabling technology
adding support to linux for
virtualization enabled the other
technologies
then we can see you look at docker what
is docker and we're going to look at
docker's images and containers so we
actually dock is going to be a bit of a
threat throughout the course itself so
this won't be the only time you'll see
daca there are at least
two or three other sections later on in
the program where um we look at other
aspects of docker because docker is
quite complex
i'm going to set up a docker registry
which is important that's where you
store the images
and then look at a docker machine which
enables you to create and control
remote instances the idea being that um
you don't have to go to different
machines to set up dock you can just do
it from one central location so we'll be
looking at
several different aspects of dhaka in
this in this lesson
so good to look at virtualization what's
the need for it and what implementations
have we got
so what is the problem
well typically in the old days or the
traditional way of doing things the
a particular computer a piece of
hardware had a single operating system
running on it and then the operating
system had a number of applications
running on top of that
so what we want to do is
make better use the actual hardware so
we take the hardware we put a
virtualization layer inside it on top of
it and then we can run a number of
different operating systems or a number
of different copies of the same
operating system on the same physical
machine
and you probably find that many of the
desktops you get in place of work may
well be virtual desktops because that's
the way a lot of companies have gone
so we've got a versioning problem and
this is this that um you might want to
have applications running on multiple
platforms and they want to run on
different operating systems
some say require linux some require
windows some require osx
and different versions of the same
operating system you'll find for example
that some things will not run on certain
versions of certain operating systems
so for example as we'll see later on
docker only runs on windows version 10
and only certain versions of version 10
and there's also a dependency problem
you have applications which are
dependent on a third-party library of
some kind
whatever that party might be it might be
something like an encryption library or
a graphics library or whatever it
happens to be
if you get two different applications
which both require a different version
of the same library it's very difficult
to have them both on the same machine
because you're going to get conflicts
because typically you can't have two
versions of the same thing on many
installations
so that's the
sort of situation we've got to deal with
so
graphics libraries media libraries
they've got different versions and
certain applications require certain
versions of each library so that's a
problem we need to consider
so we could have separate environments
but that's going to get complicated
we've got to have a development
environment some
testing
environments production environments all
the different ones we don't really want
to have
different
installations on different pieces of
hardware for a startup it's going to be
expensive
you have to have lots of um different
pieces of hardware all tied up with a
particular piece of software then all
the combinations of operating systems
and dependency libraries just gets
completely out of hand so we need to
solve that problem and this is where
we're going which is a very important
aspect of the devops environment we can
solve these problems in a very
simplistic and elegant way
so in a large organization the computing
requirements are very different so for
example everybody might be running the
same version of windows so a lot of
companies are still using xp aren't they
because they don't want to move to
anything later
but the problem is
different roles in the organization
needs different configurations so
somebody in a sort of admin role would
probably only want a basic installation
with
word processing software
microsoft office or something like that
developers need compilers and all
developers talk to development tools
ides
and access to all sorts of things
and so you need different specifications
of
software combinations for each
individual employee technically
so that makes it difficult because
you've got to roll out the environment a
new employee starts they've got to get
an environment it's going to be the
right one for their role
then you've got the problems of updating
the software
and applying fixes and patches to the
operating system
then what happens if you want to have a
meeting and do live demonstrations
that's a bit of a pain you don't really
want to cart your laptop or your um
desktop is even worse into the
conference room
although a laptop can help this sort of
situation but then even then you've got
problems with versioning and what you
can and can't put on a laptop within the
organization
so the next approach which came along
was multiple boot machines
so have multiple operating systems on
the same physical hardware but they all
typically reside on a separate disk or a
separate disk petition
that requires a complex boot manager of
which there are several around you're
probably familiar with grub which is the
the one of choice for most linux
distributions these days rubs that
grub's quite actually easy to configure
i was having to play with it myself
today
i um installed a version of um debian
8.7 linux on a laptop spare laptop i got
and the first thing that happened i lost
the root password
and i had to do a root password reset
which is not easy
i hadn't done one for quite a long time
it didn't take very long but grub was
the way to get there okay
um there's other problems with
associated things as well as issues
if you have a linux distribution
sitting alongside another distribution
such as a windows hall
any other um operating system the
chances are that linux will be able to
read the operating systems drip disks
because linux has got drivers for
reading all sorts of different formats
of hard drive
and so
you've got a complete compromise of
security the operating system
thinks it's securing its disks but in
fact linux can bypass everything
in fact if you boot a linux system on a
dvd or some other bootable medium you
can do all sorts of horrible things to
any machine because the linux will just
be able to read anything it likes
grab files anything
so now we have the concept of a virtual
machine
now it's quite interesting in this day
and age we think we're pretty advanced
um
in terms of computing power and all that
sort of stuff but in terms of software
we actually haven't come a long way
um virtual machines and lots of other
technologies we start throwing these
words around like restful web services
are they new no they're 20 years old
virtualization is it new no it's 45
years old they're 55 years old okay
it's really quite old because early
mainframe computers
used a form of virtualization
to do multitasking between programs
effectively what happened was each
program had to appear to have full
access to the machine
and so a virtual environment was um
was created for that so the early
versions
of operating systems which i think going
back to say 1980s
had the word the left vm in them
somewhere another because they were
actually running virtual machines
and um
then what happened was in the
late 1990s
intel produced the
cpu which was the first
proper cpu if you like that could do
proper multitasking as we know it today
and if you know what you're doing you
could take an 80386 cpu and you could
switch it into what's known as protected
mode and then you could access a number
of virtual 80386 8086 rather virtual
machines
i actually remember doing this
windows used to take over the machine he
wasn't using the full capability of the
h3o6 it was using what was called real
mode
i wrote an assembler program in windows
which i ran what it did was it executed
um some this assembler code it created a
data structure
and pushed the machine into its full
blown protected mode and then what i did
was i dumped the windows operating
system into a virtual 8086 environment
and it was quite unaware of it and at
the same time i had a little command
console at the bottom of the screen
where i could type compounds and play
around with things so that's been around
for a long time
so the 8386 allowed you to do this kind
of stuff
vmware which you may have heard of is
one of the big players in virtualization
and they started around about that time
and
they've been
building
virtualization software platforms ever
since
so what does he use a virtual machine
just to put that in perspective
if you think about it as a petition
you take all the hardware resources
you've got
and petition it in such a way that you
can install an operating system on part
of those resources and they can't see
each other and you have some underlying
software which is the virtualization
layer which controls everything it's
like an opera it is probably an
operating system its own right almost
certainly
the virtualization software is going to
be based on a linux kernel
so they're great for setting up
well-defined environments virtual
machines are basically a collection of
files they tend to be rather large files
but you can simply copy these files
around
and just run them on the machines all
you need is the virtualization software
running on the host operating system
you can run several different operating
systems on the same machine at the same
time all running as virtual machines
and so we don't have multiple boot
machines anymore really we don't really
need them you can use virtualization to
do so especially with recent advances
in terms of virtualization software
there are basically two types the type
one and the type two
the virtualization software is known as
a hypervisor is the name for it
and what it does is it gives the guest
operating system
access to what it thinks is hardware it
may be the real hardware or it may
actually emulate the hardware in some
way that can solve some quite nasty
problems
so a type one is called a native or a
bare metal hypervisor you install the
hypervisor as the main operating system
if you like on the hardware it's
typically based on linux because the
linux kernel has got all sorts of good
stuff in there for doing it in fact
there's a thing called kvm the
kernel virtual machine which is part of
the linux kernel which enables
virtualization almost for free
and then what you do is you run your
guest operating system effectively as a
process on the on the host it's a little
bit more than it's just a single process
but it's it's a kind of a petitioning
and these are normally for the high-end
servers so if you've got a data center
you'll be using type one hypervisors
so you've got oracle vm server citrix
send server
vm
where esx is a popular one microsoft
hyper-v it's another one they all do the
same kind of thing
so this is the diagram you've got the
hardware the hypervisor sits on top of
it then on top of that you've got a
number of operating systems and each
operating system runs
a number of applications so that's the
kind of tree structure we've got
so a type 2 hypervisor or a hosted
hypervisor is basically a program
running on a conventional operating
system
and what it does is it does the
necessary mapping so when the guest
operating system makes a system call
it goes to the hypervisor software which
then maps it onto the host operating
system
operating system calls just kind of acts
as a mapping layer between the two
it's used on desktops and laptops and
that includes the likes of vmware player
vmware workstation oracle virtualbox are
technically hype type 2 hypervisors
although this is a bit blurred as we'll
see in a moment
so i type two high fives that looks like
this you've got the hardware you've got
the operating system you run the
hypervisor some kind of application
and then that hypervisor then runs
a number of operating systems which in
turn run a number of applications so
that's the type 2 hypervisor model it
can cause a few problems particularly
performance because one thing you
haven't got any control of
is the host operating system it can take
resources which you just can't free up
so the technology
the way it's evolved so the 8386 i
mentioned before could virtualize the
processor which predated it basically
put it in a different mode and it just
it was a very easy way of doing you just
set up a container for it
then some important developments
happened
the um the chip manufacturers
typically
intel and amd
what they did was they started to add
extra instructions to the cpu
which were the virtual machine
extensions or vmx instructions
and then also very important the virtual
machine monitor vmm
instructions sorry the virtual machine
monitors the software which enables you
to enable you to access those vmx
extractions the vmx
extensions basically
allow you to get control of the cpu in a
more powerful way than the normal
operating systems though because these
instructions when enacted when activated
effectively undermine
the um the existing operating system
so you have a virtual machine monitor
which is basically a type of hypervisor
which invokes these special instructions
and then it allows the multiple
operating systems to work running
virtual parallel so what happens is
typically you've got the um
the host operating system
and then you've got the
say the vmware player or something that
the hypervisor program running
what happens is that the hypervisor
program invokes these special
instructions which puts
in a special
ring of
control
which is underneath the host operating
system
then when it runs another operating
system effectively the host operating
system and the guest are running in
parallel and they can actually access
the same hardware and they can share the
hardware
that's an interesting
development so then that interest
improved even further with the memory
management unit
because the memory management was
difficult because what you have to do is
map memory pages and this greatly
simplified it
and meant that the
the virtual machines could access the
memory directly by remapping it
and then they added extended page tables
which makes it even more powerful and
solved other memory management problems
and once you've got all these three
levels of functionality built into your
cpu
then you can do some really clever
things in terms of virtualization
so effectively now the distinction
between a type 1 and type 2 hypervisor
is very vague
because if your mods if your cpu
supports full hardware virtualization
then you can effectively have a type one
which is a type two which is effectively
a type one
um you need to check your chips sets you
can find out from the intel sites in
other ones what the facility is
but um and also because of the way that
it works i think you might be able to
guess when i said that
the virtualization software can invoke
these instructions which underpin the um
the host operating system there's an
implication of security there and you
can actually completely compromise
security if you know what you're doing
it has been established that that is the
case
so by default
the um security extensions are switched
off in the bias
in the in the firmware if you're trying
to run the virtualization the first
thing you should do is go into your bios
and try and switch it on otherwise your
virtual machines will run incredibly
slowly okay
so now then we've got some
virtualization in hardware the hosting
guest can basically both use the real
hardware
and you've got other things like the um
kvm is a kernel-based virtual machine
built into linux
the freebsd beehive kernel modules
effectively
can turn
a type 2 hypervisor into type 1. so
we've got full control
okay it's all good stuff
but there are problems with virtual
machines
it's not the perfect world but it's
better than having dual boot um or
multiple machines
now the problem one of the problems is
the virtual machines are full operating
systems
and they're typically installed into the
hypervisor
via an iso image or a dvd or some form
normally an iso image
and then you need to install the
application software on top of it and
configure it such like installing which
is like exactly the same
as installing a complete operating
system every time you create a virtual
machine obviously once you've done it
you can copy it easily enough but that's
the first setup is it's like more
complex
then there's other issues
um there's a difference with 64-bit and
32-bit
if you've got a 32-bit operating system
your hardware is probably 64-bit these
days most modern almost all of modern
hardware is 64-bit but there are 32-bit
operating systems around so the 32-bit
operating system runs on a 64-bit guest
if you want to do virtual run virtual
machines for a start-off
you can run a 64-bit
guest on top of a 32-bit host
only if you've got the hardware
extensions
you know on the cpu and switched on
there's another problem
in that the
32-bit machine will do some memory
mapping and maybe a lot of the memory
will disappear and is not available
which means
probably won't leave enough memory left
over to run the guest i've had that
problem in the past that you've only got
like one gig of memory available for the
guest which isn't enough
the other problem is that the virtual
machines
are very big
typically they're broken into files so
if you've got say a
60 gigabyte hard drive on your virtual
machine it'll be broken up
into
four gigabyte files a whole bunch of
them and they'll just grow as you need
to add them
so the two gig chunks are for convenient
it's basically for doing file transfers
but how do you get them to transfer
across the internet for example or copy
them on drives
have you got a big enough usb stick or
or drive
typically what you do
is you need to break the virtual machine
into chunks
and compress it um the program 7-zip is
very good at doing this you can say
right i want you to take this whole
virtual machine
i
want you to compress it and i want you
to break it into say one gigabyte chunks
and then you just transfer the one
gigabyte chunks one of the time at the
across the network then 7-zip will
reassemble and extract everything back
to the original virtual machine but it's
a bit painful i've had terrible problems
copying virtual machines it just takes
such a long time
so look at some terminology
and
we have these terms which are related
but let's make sure we're clear what
we're saying so multitasking is
basically any modern operating system
which can run multiple programs
concurrently it usually uses some kind
of time slicing to schedule the actual
processing you've obviously got more
than one cpu these days nearly all
machines have got multiple cores with
hyper threading so
you'd never really have single cpu
machines anymore
which had to do extensive time slicing
so you do get some true parallel running
multi-core what's that well that's um
where you have a
cpu as in the
the chip that you you buy which has got
more than one cpu actually built onto it
it used to be that every chip had
exactly one cpu core on it
and
what's happened is that the geometries
of the chips have got so small now that
we can't really make them any smaller so
what the chip manufacturers have done is
they put in multiple cpus on the same
physical piece of silicon
so that you've got multiple core chips
and typically you get a two core or a
four core
uh machine that's fairly normal is neat
the cpu chip has got more than one core
then you've got hyper threading where
every single cpu core
can have several instruction pointers
effectively you can run two threads
concurrently
and typically
most cores these days have got at least
two hyper threads so if you've got a
four core chip you've effectively got
eight cores eight cpus effectively
which is quite a lot of power
and virtualization
is a single computer which you partition
the hardware in such a way that each of
the partitions looks like a separate
computer okay
so that's the basics of virtualization
so if we do the knowledge check what is
type 1 virtualization virtualization
software still install directly on the
hardware
at your boot machine virtualization
software store is on a hover operating
system or a special cpu instruction set
right we seem to have a good consensus
there
yeah it's a it's virtualization software
installed directly on the hardware
i would say the distinction is very
vague these days
so now we're going to look at linux
virtualization
and this is important because
linux was the enabling tool for making
the good stuff we're going to be looking
at later on happen
and um
so the linux kernel
being open source and
being very flexible got a lot of stuff
in it it's relatively easy to add
modifications to it to do things that um
are really really useful
so when we look at tools like docker
later on although it does technically
work on other operating systems you
really need to work on linux because
linux has got the full support that it
needs
so
software installation and management
so you've got the problems of multiple
applications wearing on the same machine
may not be compatible they've got shared
libraries which have different versions
if you need to upgrade the
dependency for one application you might
break the other ones
when you remove an application do you
remove the dependencies would you leave
them behind because something else might
be using them
so there's all sorts of issues you said
dependency no longer required can you
take it away or not
you've got the packaging tools like rpm
for the um
red hat centos family of of linux's and
apt for the
debian ubuntu flavor of linux's
they have help a lot because they
package the software and they've got
clever installation and removal software
which can
handle the dependencies quite well but
they still get some dependency issues
and you can inadvertently pull in a lot
of stuff you don't actually need
so for example i was going i wanted to
install
maven on a particular machine i used apt
to do it it pulled in all sorts of
rubbish that i really didn't want so i
had to remove it all and install maven
manually because it was the dependency
rules
for the package was too complex
so we've had got the term unix jails you
might have heard the term jail
in the world of apple with ios you might
have heard the term jailbreak
um basically
all mobile phones
effectively implement jails because all
the applications on the phone are
effectively isolated from each other it
is particularly true of ios
less so of android
and
if you want to get outside of these
containers you need to jailbreak your
machine
which requires quite a nasty hack but it
can be done
i've never quite had the
courage to do it on ios and i wasn't
able to do it under android but it's
i know the principle is fairly easy
because i managed to
make um
the route pass whatever linux machine a
few minutes today so
so what happens is that unix has had a
facility to confine applications there's
a mechanism called ch root
what it does is you can say to a program
okay
when i run you
you can only see this small section of
the file system it's very commonly done
for things like web servers and other
services you don't want the web server
to see the whole
of the um the hard drive on the machine
because if something goes wrong it could
potentially dissolve the files out serve
them all out as web content
so you use the ch root mechanism to put
your web server or your dns server into
a well-contained place
and that gives you a means of isolating
depends processes and dependencies you
do of course have to put all the
dependencies into the isolated area
which is a bit of a pain
but it is actually possible to get out
of jail
because the ch root mechanism has a
well-known
loophole for getting out
and so um
it isn't absolutely perfect so what's
happened is that another set of
technologies introduced which are called
container technologies which enable you
to make more robust jails which are hard
to get out
so that's one thing
one of my next projects is going to be
seen if i can get out of the docker jail
so um it's going to be quite an
interesting challenge
and this is known as operating system
level virtualization you basically have
an application which has a
limited set of resources available
and what actually happens is you instead
of having
a separate kernel for each os or each
application
you have a single kernel and all the
containers run as a children of this
first major the main kernel which is
really good
so how does this work
well the several things that were done
first of all
linux introduces the concepts of
namespaces
and the namespace is a wrapper around
some kind of resource
so for example processes can be put into
namespaces
um
and what happens is that every namespace
contains a number of processes
and they think it looks to them like
they've got their entire own instances
of some kind of global resource
and it's an important means of
implementing this
so basically what you can do is you can
create name spaces and you can move
process in and out of name spaces on the
fly so a running process can be moved
from one name space to another and this
controls exactly what resources that
process can see
so linux introduced a number of lane
spaces
now the um the first one c group is the
most important one because this is the
control group which is the key that
underpins
the virtualization mechanism of
containers
with ipc which is for
inter-process communication that's
shared memory and
sockets and things like that
we've got network for
network devices
so you can create virtual networks
we've got mount which is defined points
which are external volumes like discs
we've got process id which is also a
very important one you can group process
ids together so that they can't see each
other if they're in a different name
space
you've also got a namespace for users
and groups as in the login users and
groups
and then you've also got the
unix time sharing group which is not
really used anymore it's if you want to
change your host name which is something
you don't really want to do very often
if at all
so control groups what are these
the idea is a control group um is a a
petition of resources
and starting with google
google seemed to have innovated a number
of things in 2006
and they started a project called
process containers
which was an extension of the linux
kernel
the linux kernel team merged these
changes into the
2.6.24 kernel and it's been there ever
since
so what happens is that a control group
will say
contain a number of cpus
and a certain amount of memory
and then into a control group
you put a number of processes
so for example
in that case we've got the control group
which has got
cpu six and seven another control group
has got cpus one two three and five
so that any process that's in control
the
group one web will only have c2 cpus
the any processes in c group in group
two db will see four cpus likewise the
memory is allocated
in a three to one ratio with a two to
one ratio across those control groups so
it means you can petition the actual
resources like cpu and memory network
devices and other things like that
and then into these control groups then
you put the processes into the control
groups
and they only see a restricted part of
the full system it's all controlled by
the single kernel which is the
host operating
system
control groups can be in a hierarchy
and so
the um
hierarchy can be attached to a number of
subsystems which are pieces of
functionality and each control group
inherits from its parents
and so um the higher c group hierarchy
is a partition of the process in this
system what that means is that
all the processes in the system belong
to one single c group
and each process
is in a single c group
and processes start in the same c group
as their parents but they can be moved
around
so
for example you can start a container up
and then you can start the process and
then move them into another c group so
they've got different access to the
program that started them
which is how these containers work
now to run the analogy if you think
about linux processes they are also
organized into a hierarchy
every process in linux or unix has a
parent process
and when a process is started by a fork
operation where basically the process
the parent process address space is
copied
and a new program is run the child
process receives a copy of the parents
environment variables
signal handlers and open file handles
which you can do what it likes with
and so we've got this idea here we've
got the parent process as a fork which
copies itself clones itself
like exec runs a new program inside that
memory space when the child process
exits it becomes what's known as a
zombie and then the parent process must
do a weight operation to clean up the
mess and that gets rid of the zombie
process
that's the kind of process life cycle
now at the pros the processes are in a
hierarchy at the roots of the trees
process number one it's normally called
init
and it's the first program that's run by
the colonel and every process is a child
or a an ancestor of the um
or his child or his grandchild or
whatever it is off the unit process if a
the child's parent process dies before
it dies its parent becomes in it process
number one
so now we get to containers
containers we say our operating system
level virtualization so the model is
slightly different we've got the
hardware and we've got the standard
operating system
well let's say it's linux for the time
being because that's where it works best
then you've got your virtualization
layer which is going to be something
like um docker
and then you have these concepts of
containers
and
the docker program orchestrates the
containers a container is basically
a cut down file system a linux file
system
it's got all the files needed to run
typically a single application
but they're completely isolated so
container one can't see inside container
two or container three like the other
way around
the only way the containers can
communicate with each other is across
the network
or across a shared file system
so typically what will happen is each
container will contain one piece such as
say a database
or a web server and your application
in the container world will consist of a
number of containers which are
orchestrated together
and it's
a great way of doing things cloud
computing utilizes this quite
extensively
so
the cloud environments do like to
use it's a thing um google's got google
container engine which is one way of
implementing it or alternatively you can
simply run um a duck s1 which is where
you run docker across several machines
then you run containers across the
machines and they can all talk to each
other to build an application that way
so how does it work hang together
what you've got is the hardware
is controlled by the linux kernel all
the kernel is it's basically a wrapper
around the hardware
that's what a kernel's job is it just
provides a
a single interface to whatever hardware
is there in basic of a unix linux the
interface looks like a file no matter
what it is
the kernel controls the name spaces and
the control groups
it may have our old friend sc linux
which is the um security enhanced linux
which can cause more problems
than it's worth getting it to work
properly is difficult getting it to
cause problems is easy
so we'll quietly ignore sc linux for the
time being but basically the kernel
manages the namespace and control fc
groups you've got the management
interface
which then
controls the containers effectively what
it does is it installs the containers as
part of the file system
but it's a self-contained unit it uses
the name basis and control groups to
isolate it then it runs a program inside
each of the containers
in its own namespaces and c groups which
controls the uh the way that the
isolation works
effectively it's a cgh root environment
inside the container and the control
groups enforce
the use constrains those resources like
cpus and memory and network devices and
other things it's quite a neat system
so
here we've got an example of operating
systems virtualization
so we've got these containers with them
they've got a file system it's got
binaries and libraries necessary to run
the program
you've got some kind of tool
um the linux containers xc
is a set of tools for
controlling
the namespaces and control groups
there is um a
thing called lxd which is a container
hypervisor built on top of lxc it's
actually designed by the ubuntu group
and it is a form of container hypervisor
there's also docker
which is
a hypervisor built on top of it's
actually not alexey because they rewrote
it so they've got their own bespoke
version of the
the management tools in docker
there's also another one called rocket
you might have heard of it's associated
with core os that's another one
so if you build a um an image from
docker lxd can run it and rocket can run
it so they're all interchangeable
because all they are all a container is
is a
cut down file system with all the
libraries and executables needed to run
an application
a supporting kernel and one of these
tools like lxd docker or rocket
yeah i think you can even do it withoxy
actually but it's a bit more painful
now this is where it gets really neat
there's a concept of a union file system
and it's been around for a while it's um
it's
available for linux and the various bsd
flavors of unix
and
what it is is that you can effectively
have a file system
which is layered you could put a layer
on top so effectively you can
merge things so what you do is you start
off with a base layer
which has got certain files installed on
it then you overlay another layer on top
of it and what it does effectively it
forms a union of the two
so if you've got this
the same directory on both with
different files you end up with the same
direction with the with both sets of
files
there is a hierarchy that if you get two
exact file paths the same in two layers
the one on top takes precedent
or you've got some ways of um giving it
a priority as well so what you do is you
build up
your file system in layers like an
opinion building up these layers
and they're called branches
and they can be read only or write read
write so typically these are used
extensively containers are always built
from these layered file systems you
start off with something basic like a
flavor of linux
and then you add a layer of libraries
and then you add your application layer
and then you maybe add your data layer
to it
and then finally you add a writable
layer and then execute it so it's a very
powerful mechanism
and then do some really clever caching
as well
so
the idea of this is then you can have a
read-only file system and then put a
writable layer on top of it so that you
can write to the file system you can't
change any of the files but you can hide
them
so you might have heard of not picks it
was a um cut down version of line that
you basically could wear it on a memory
stick or a dvd image
that but obviously that's right read
only so what he did was he put a
writable layer over it in memory which
you enabled you to create
files and make changes on top of it so
you have this
layered image
so that's the enabling technology
so what is operating system level
virtualization
a hit virtualization software installed
on the host machine a dual boot machine
a host operating system with a guest
operating system or kernel support for
multi multi-isolated user space
environments
okay
getting a number
of different ones it is actually d this
is a kernel support for multiple
isolated user
spaceship environments there is a bit of
a involved because you do need the
software that can be broken okay so um
but technically it's the um the kernel
support for these namespaces and control
groups which enable you to do these
things
so let's have a look at docker
so um we've got said there's a number of
different container management tools
there's lxd there's docker and there's
rocket
docker i think have kind of rushed
themselves to
get to a good place in the market and
they're they're gaining a lot of
attention though i must admit i was a
little shocked when i was playing around
with docker recently i found some rather
serious security problems
which i um i actually reported one of
them to the docker team and they said oh
that's normal behavior and i was a
little shocked about that but
never mind
i'm going to have to investigate this
much more detail
so what is docker
well basically
it's a software containerization
platform it's basically you've got um
a docker daemon which is a process which
runs
and it enables you to create
and
run
docker
containers that's what it's all about
so
typically you only worked on um
linux but a docker container typically
it starts off with a base linex
operating system
and
it can be based on any of the popular
operating systems people have actually
made various um
cut down versions you don't want the
full-blown operating system with all the
files and stuff you don't want all the
boot scripts and all that nonsense um so
you can get a base image
which is safe for
debian or ubuntu or centos
any of the popular operating systems as
a base image
there's one that's really interesting
called alpine
alpine is a really really cut down image
the um
we're talking sort of like the other
ones are in the order of large numbers
of megabytes alpine we're talking
kilobytes it's really small and really
compact
and so what it does is docker provides
the the boundary the jail for running it
so it means that you can't get out of it
um as i say i think the
story's still open as to whether it is
possible to get out of it but um
there are ways you can
influence the outside world i know for a
fact but
as to whether you can really get out of
these i'm not sure
um so the docker image is a foundation
for any container
so what you do is you as we'll see later
you take the a base image you add layers
to it to form another image which is the
image is a read-only copy then when you
create a container it puts a writable
layer on top of it and it's executed so
that's the the difference
so
basically what you've got is the normal
operating system with its kernel
and then you've got docker
and then you've got
any containers that are managed by
docker
so
was originally for linux it really still
is
it requires
the kernel container functionality which
means you've got to have a linux kernel
above that minimum level where it was
introduced
it has to be 30 64 bit
and so now it has to be a version 310 or
higher to get it to work
and it runs on
most flavors of linux for some you can
get it with an rpm or apt package
others it's a little bit more painful
there's usually a way of installing it
if you go to the docker website
it gives you instructions as to how to
install it on each of the operating
systems some it's very trivial some
requires quite a lot of work
but it's um it's a one-off thing once
you've installed it it's fairly
straightforward and actually once you've
got on one machine
you can actually use docker manager to
get it to
install other machines although i've had
a few problems with um centos
and docker
yes good question docker containers
use networking to communicate it's
actually there's only two ways a
container can communicate with another
container by a network or by a common
shared at volume some quite like a disk
space
the containers have their own virtual
network interface control cards
so
basically what to give you the full
story
when docker starts up it creates a
virtual network
inside its environment which is
completely separate for the um
from the the network the computer's on
there is a gateway between the host
network and the docker internal network
with jockery manages
whenever it starts a
container
it uses typically dhcp
to give it an ip address on that
internal network so all the containers
running on the same machine
by default
are on the same network but they can't
see outside that network by default
um
that's an interesting question does
docker do the job of jenkins no
jenkins is an integration continuous
integration tool
docker is purely
a container management tool
to put it in perspective later on we'll
be finding this out you can you can
download a docker container containing
jenkins
yeah
so if you want something like jenkins or
any other application you can get
containers with them on
so yes it's the the host then the
docker virtual machine system
and then you've got the doc containers
managed by the docker environment
it'll become more apparent as we go on
but it's just yeah there's quite a lot
of pieces to it aren't there
so
docker for os x
um
will docker run on windows 7 not
natively
there is a way of doing it
basically you can you can run docker in
a virtual machine
no as i said before docker's not the
only tool for container management lxd
and rocket also do it
i'll argue
rocket may be better i'm
something i've got a project underway at
the moment to investigate all this
technology exactly where everything
stands because i need to figure out a
few things about how docker works
because i say i've found a security
problem that i'm rather unhappy about
so
okay so for os x
they
didn't support osx directly
um until
earlier last year
forgetting we're in the new year now
aren't we um it was about the middle of
last year
they introduced a
native version of os x built on the x
hive hypervisor because osx is basically
a flavor of bsd unix
you have to have a fairly recent mac
because it has to have a cpu with the
memory management and extended page
table support otherwise it will not work
and you need to have at least the 70
version 10 10 3
and at least 4 gig of ram
um it does work and i have got it
installed on my mac here
but
networking is badly broken
so
it is supposed to be the case that the
docker
demon process
listens on tcp port
for incoming network connections the os
x version does not and cannot there is
some kind of problem between the duck
guys and apple
where apple won't release
the necessary information to be able to
do it properly i found it very
frustrating so if you've got a mac you
can install docker on it you can run
containers locally and the containers
can talk to each other locally over the
network
but you cannot communicate with an
external docker implementation from osx
directly so that's why i've been
installing
um debian linux on a separate separate
laptop so i've got a full blown docker
that actually does work
yeah the networking is terrible under os
x for dhaka
darker for windows again
there was there wasn't one available
until the middle of last year
it's now it is supported it requires
certain versions of windows 10
they say they might extend it to other
versions
the net limited network report yeah
under linux is no problem at all ever
because the linux networking just works
i'm not sure the full story about
windows i've never tried it
but certainly osx for the networking is
quite badly broken
so the docker for windows requires
certain versions of windows 10
it requires you to install the hyper-v
package which is the microsoft
hypervisor package
and that means that you can't run
virtualbox if you've got ipv installed
virtualbox will not work
and basically it provides the
virtualization environment
and makes
windows look a bit like a linux kernel
make this work it's a bit of a hybrid
approach actually
now
for other computers the starker toolbox
now this was how you used to run it on
osx and windows before the middle of
last year
so if you don't meet the requirements
then you use docker toolbox
what docker toolbox is is an oracle
virtual box virtual machine with docker
installed inside it in a it basically
runs a linux operating system with
docker installed on it in a virtual
machine
okay but that does work
properly and it'll work
well it'll do the networking and
everything because effectively you're
using a linux virtual machine here and
that solves the problems that there were
with docker
so docker's client server it is got a
client called docker
yeah the toolbox will also will
definitely work on windows even for
windows 7. as long as it's 64-bit rather
any
version of any 64-bit operating system
that can run virtualbox can run
the uh duck of the toolkit which is the
way around is if you haven't got
available linux box say um
i've got a i've got a few spare laptops
and i've just installed linux on it just
for docker
oh and by the way the docker
client
on os x will talk to a docker server on
linux
because it can do the networking it's
just the server can't do the networking
so the client uses a restful api over
http
um
it prefers to use a local unix socket
you actually have to enable the http
explicitly
on most systems to make it work it
doesn't listen on the tcp port by
default
so you've got the docker daemon that
does everything
it does building the running the
distributing downloading everything of
containers so the client just basically
tells the demon what to do
there's also a registry which is where
docker images are stored they can be in
docker hub which is a central one you
could have your own private one or the
certain vendors also provide registries
we'll look at those in more detail later
on today
so
got to understand here this very
important distinction we have the images
and the containers
so a docker image
is like a read-only template you start
off with a base image which you normally
download from docker hub
because you could build your own but
it's painful
then what you do is you add layers to
that image
and how you do that
i'll come back to but what you do then
to give it an image
you can create a container so what
happens is you go to doc you say docker
run
and give it an image
and what it'll do is it'll take that
image copy it put another layer on top
of it
which is writable
and then executes a program which you
can specify or use the default one which
happens to be
hard code into it
that runs as a container the container
can be started and stopped into all
sorts of other things
and then what you can do
is once you've got the container you can
add software to the rightful layer of
the container
and then you could stop the container
and save it
as an image
so that's how you add layers to an image
take an image make a container from it
install software into the writable layer
and then save it as another image and
build up the layers like that it can be
done in several different ways but we'll
be and we'll be doing both of those ways
but remember that containers if you
delete a container the writable layer
gets destroyed
and so the only way you can save it is
if you do actually do what's called a
commit
yeah basically every layer is saved as a
separate file
which the all the images are composite
if you download an image from say um
docker hub and you say get the jenkins
image you'll find that it's got about 20
layers
so what it's done it started off with
the base layer and added all these extra
layers on top of it as it built up the
application
so when you
make a container
add some files to it and commit it it'll
create another layer which becomes
associated with that a new image yeah
so containers can be started stopped run
deleted
and um
they're they often have various ways of
configuring themselves they're quite
it's quite powerful it's quite a neat
system
just have to put all the pieces together
to get
to grips with it
so it's the union file system i've
already described basically what happens
here
you you take a base image create a
container install software save it as a
layer and make another image
docker hub is a repository in the net
in the cloud which enables you to
download pre-built darker images so if
you say oh i want centos linux
you say docker paul
sent off and it will go to docker hub
and grab it copy the image and download
it
okay you could have your own account on
dot hub if you want and store your
images there if you wish
so it's basically building up these
layers so here we've got an example
you've got all these all the um
layers have really exotic names which
you've got big hexadecimal strings
so this is showing that you've got every
layer every image has got a history each
layer was something added to a base
image
so
running containers you've got the docker
run command and basically it takes an
image and creates a container by adding
the rightful layer
if when you give it a run command you
specify an image name
what it does first of all it looks in a
local repository that it manages for
that image
if it finds it'll use it if it doesn't
find it
it'll do a pull from docker from a
docker hub
by default or any other docker registry
you can specify
that means it'll download
the layers that make up the image
and then build up the um the image from
the layers and it could take a little
while and you see the process very
clearly when you do the
the darker commands
then it creates a new container
using the file system on the image by
adding another layer on top of it which
is a read write layer he creates a
network interface if you want one
assigns an ip address it basically uses
dhcp to do that
by default
it may connect input and output streams
for you take from your keyboard and then
it'll specify execute a specified
application
and then you're basically running inside
the container
so if you want to start a shell inside
the container that's fine you just do
that
and you look like you're inside a
different
environment which is the contents of the
container
and so all the containers basically run
as child processes of the demon process
i'm not actually familiar with vagrant
i'll come back to you on that one
so here is the
way you do things
if you want to download an image you do
a docker pull command docker pull space
and then you give the image name colon
version number now every image has got a
color latest on docker hub so if you
want the latest version you specify
colon latest or otherwise
you specify a specific version number
so paul guarantees it's there if you
just do a run
um docker run center column latest
it will do a pull if it doesn't already
exist on the local machine
and
what you can do there what this is doing
in those last three lines
there's docker run centos latest who am
i so it'll start up the container
and execute the who am i command and
then terminate
so the image that the container will
stop when the whom i command is finished
and the output of the who am i command
will appear on your screen
likewise with pw and d and date okay
so that's the
docker run command
so
if you want to run the container
interactively which is actually very
useful to find out whether it's working
or not
you use the minus i and minus t switches
to
keep the sound input open make
interactive allocator pseudo tty device
i normally just type minus i t
is the docker run minus i t
centos colon latest and then a command
and so slash bin slash bash will run the
bash shell
what will happen there is you'll get a
root prompt
from a bash shell and you are inside the
container so you can use all the
commands that are available within that
centos image
to to look around the container
and
the moment you exit the bash shell with
ctrl d or exit
the container will stop running it
doesn't go away it stops running that's
all
if you want to find out what containers
are running on a machine you use docker
ps
and
you can also do the stats command docker
stats which will find tell you what the
um
container resource usage is it gives you
a continuous thing you have to do a
control c to exit it docker ps is very
useful what's wrong
now when you run a container
it gives the container a name
and the default name it makes up
something rather odd some kind of
comical name like hungry lumiere or
whatever it is it's different every time
so what i always do is do docker run
minus i t minus minus name and then a
sensible name for the container
because what happens is that when you
want to do any operations on the
container like stop it or remove it you
need to give the name or the id the id
is a huge hexadecimal string which you
really don't want to deal with let's
copy and paste
so giving it a sensible name means it's
easy to find you can do this docker ps
to find it but um it's easy if you've
given his name so
in this case you run it like that if i
did docker stop centos from another
window
um it'll stop the centos container and
notice some people get confused one
thing you cannot run docker commands
inside a container so you need to be
aware whether you're in the container or
outside of it
because docker is not installed inside
the container
there's also a docker ps minus a which
lists all containers including stopped
containers and docker rm
container name
removes the container deletes the
container which means that anything in
the writable layer is destroyed
as a docker rm minus f
also will stop a starter container and
then delete it
you can also attach a container this is
not a right thing to do but it seems
quite interesting if you run a container
like this first command which is running
a shell bash then on a second terminal
you go docker attach centos
you'll get a second terminal center
session to the same container with the
same content so if you type a command in
one terminal you'll see the command and
its output appear in the other terminal
at the same time
so both sessions see the same inputs and
outputs and you can detach yourself
using control p control q if you want to
do that something you don't normally do
like that but you can you can attach to
a container which is um
disconnected you haven't got anything
connected to it interactively
so this docker stop stops the container
normally containers were in the
background the steaming processes so
that's when you use the stop command
it's also you've got to do a stop minus
t which will do a timeout
now interestingly enough
the main process is process id number
one the processes id number one in unix
is always in it in a container it's the
one you executed which may be a shell or
it may be an application but it's always
process one and it's sent to sig term or
and then possibly a thick kill if it
doesn't terminate within the default
time period that kills the container
effectively it stops it it doesn't
remove the container it just stops the
application
you can restart if you wish
you can also pause containers
it's something i don't tend to do
it doesn't use the six stop sig card
mechanism because the processes the the
visibility of the signals
uses a c group mechanism for doing that
but you can pause them and unpause them
if you wish
yes good point
docker
you could do docker minus minus help or
you could do docker run minus minus help
or docker
um images minus minus help you can use
that for anything to get a list of all
the commands and their options
a pause where you stop the container put
to sleep
it just stops it immediately
and then you can wake it up again later
if you need to stop it temporarily for
some reason
so you can do docker start
and you can reconnect an interactive
session if you do that so you can do a
start or attach
removing containers you use docker rm
and the name of the containers if you do
minus f it will stop a container if you
do a docker r m on a running container
it will not do it you have to force it
or you do a docker stop first
a quick way of doing getting rid of all
the containers
is if you do docker ps minus aq
it doesn't list do a full listing like
normally does it just lists all the
container identifiers as a big list
so if you use command substitution dot
rm dollar brackets docker ps minus aq
it'll delete every single container on
your machine
which is a quick way of cleaning
everything up
and most often
you have your containers running a
service of their demon processes so you
do docker run minus d
and typically name them as well so if
you're running an nginx web server do
docker run minus d
minus minus name web server ngin ng inx
and you can also do a docker kill if you
wish to
do that
you can use you can do a stop as well
okay
so that's a flavor for docker now docker
is installed on our virtual machines
that we installed yesterday
so what i'm going to do now is give you
a url to get you to the instructions
for this lab
so again we're going to be using the
google cloud
instance we did yesterday
let's say docker has already been
installed
and it's up ready to go so we just want
to do is have a go at connect your
virtual machine using ssh
use the various docker commands
to um to try out a few things so just
have a play around with um
running
containers trying different things and
um
see how you get along so
it's going to be i think this exercise
will probably take about half an hour so
allow half an hour for this if you let
me know when you're finished or if or
message me
if you've had any problems or when
you're finished okay
okay so that's the first installment of
docker uh there's quite a lot of
questions there and they're very keen to
get onto more of it we'll cover some of
the things that you've been asking later
on because
we've only just really scratched the
surface of docker what it does um
building images all that comes in the
next sections as we go along
okay
um to answer the question on vagrant
vagrant actually sits on top of
virtualization it's a development
environment for controlling
the various versions so it's it sits on
top of the the kind of concept of things
like docker
right so
that's docker and the basic commands
use docker minus minus help
i don't know if you did a docker images
and compared the size of um
alpine versus debian it's a lot a lot
smaller alpine is tiny
so it's good for um
building really lightweight applications
you can get away with the minimal amount
of software that's installed on
alpine it's a good base image you don't
need all the heavyweight stuff that
the main distros like debian ubuntu
centos actually have available it's not
necessary
so we have a knowledge check for that
so what is the docker image
a running software application a
read-only template campaign containing
complete software application increased
operating system or a running docker
application
okay
so it's b it is a read-only template
containing a complete software
application it can contain more than one
but normally the spirit of things is to
have a single application and have
multiple containers particularly if you
make them really lightweight out in
containers like um
if you have the images are really
lightweight based on alpine
then it doesn't have an overhead
significant overhead to have multiple
containers rather than multiple
applications in the same container
and they can't interact with each other
except through the network or possibly
shared um
devices so it's a good way of doing
things
so now we can look at docker images so
this is where they answer some of the
questions how do you make a docker image
well this is how we're going to do that
so
docker
hub is basically the repository for
images it's maintained by the darker
people and
it's the default location for everything
so there's a number of base images there
they're typically based on a linux
distribution
so
for example
you can use centos colon latest that can
be used as a base image or any other one
that you might want to use see alpine
has an advantage of being very very
lightweight very very small
so what you then do is you build layers
on top of a base image
and you can do that in two ways you can
either run the image as a container
and then add the layers manually
or you can automate it using the docker
build process and we'll look at both of
those mechanisms
sometimes you need to use a hybrid of
the two
there's also a docker search facility
which searches for docker hubs if you go
to docker search centos
it'll give you a list of all the images
which match
the pattern sent off and you'll find
that different distributions or
different images
there will be several different hits
from the search
typically for say operating systems
docker hub has a kind of an official
version
and then other people will store their
versions of it on docker hub because
anybody can create a docker hub account
and store their images there and make
them searchable by other people
so if you search for something like
jenkins or
diet or something like that you probably
find you get a lot of hits because
you've got different people have built
them in slightly different ways
so if you're installing software
you can run your container and then you
can install images using yum or apt-get
depending on which flavor of linux
you're using
be careful about doing that
the first thing you often have to do is
like an app to get in update
that adds all sorts of stuff that you
probably don't need because it has to
download all of its um updated um
registry files
also yemen apt-get also pull in
dependencies of any application and you
can get all sorts of stuff you didn't
want
so to give an example that
i've got
i wanted to install java 1.8 i didn't
want the open jdk i wanted the
oracle version
if i wanted to install maven using yum
or apt-get i was actually on for a
centos it pulled an open jdk 1.7 which i
didn't want
and it just complicated things added all
sorts of extra layers which i didn't
need so i ended up installing maven
explicitly myself
so it's often easier to install software
from tables or for from direct rpm or
deep.dev packages or archives
or just from files than to use the
packaging tools
if you're using alpine you've got its
own package manager called apk which is
the equivalent of apt-get
so dealing with images to list the
images to docker images that gives you a
list of all the images stored on the
local machine
if you want to get rid of an image use
docker rmi
name of the image or the id of the image
you'll find that you soon get a very
large number of images and sometimes
that's a bit of a clean up
so i recently took one of those and got
rid of an awful lot of images i just
didn't want on my disk
so the base images
okay the same just base image is based
on the centos operating system which
isn't
the full-blown system so many commands
are not there
so for example no other boot scripts or
boot mechanisms are present on the image
you don't need them because you never
boot a container
if you boot an immediate build something
it means you've got a kernel because you
boot a kernel and then that starts the
rest of the system you never boot a
container you just load it and run a
program
so all that stuff will be missing all
the um
system system five startup or whatever
it is would not be there
uh centastic doesn't have the which
command or the ifconfig commands
so what you need to do sometimes is just
install some of the basics and have your
own
version of the image which has got some
of the tools that you need
curiously enough i found when i was
playing around with these things that
one thing i really wanted was ifconfig
just to find out what the network looked
like because i was having networking
problems and so the first thing i had to
do
was a yum install miners why net tools
because that's where the
ifc
command resides in the net tools package
and the which command was also very
useful for finding out where the
executable was
so
you may have to install things using yum
for very simple things but try not to
install something which is heavy weight
i'm going to pull in lots of unneeded
dependencies
so here is an example
using the interactive mechanism
you run the container
and if you do that run minus it it's
always a good idea to go minus minus
name to give it a sensible name rather
than one of the auto generated ones
so give it a name and then specify the
image to start off with
then i'm running the yum install
command so run yum install minus y
um yum asks a lot of questions if you go
yummy store minus y
the system automatically answers yes to
every single question that you're asked
it's a very useful thing there is
actually a unix command called yes which
just answers why why why why why and
it's used a lot to get around the
problems of being able to automate and
install
from applications which keep asking you
questions
so install the which and net tools
package and then exit the container so
the container's now stopped
but it's still on the disk and it's
still got the
which and net tools software installed
in the writable layer on the container
so i can use a docker diff on centos and
i'll show you the changes that tends to
produce a rather verbose output which
shows you every single file that's
changed and it's probably not that
useful
the docker commit sent us centos net
what that does is it takes the container
called centos
and creates one of these read-only
images called centos net with that
writable layer now as a fixed layer on
top of the image
then i can quite happily go docker rm
centos and delete it
then i can do a docker run now minus
minus rm as we saw in the exercise that
says
delete the container when it exits don't
leave it lying around and so if you're
doing something interactive where you
don't want to keep it to do a commit
i strongly recommend using the minus
minus rm switch i usually do go i
usually do the other way around
docker run minus i t minus minus rm
and then you don't need to give it a
name actually because the name will go
away straight away as soon as you exit
then the name of the image
and then possibly the name of the
command
you can use docker inspect to exceed the
layers you get a json array back it's
very verbose and contains a lot of
information
you could do a
search on it looking for certain strings
in the json format if you want to to
look for a certain things like
architecture but the docker inspector is
quite useful it tells you all about the
um
either the images or containers actually
works on both
it'll tell you what the layers are in
images
containers it'll tell you all about the
networking and where the image was and
all that kind of stuff
well that's all very well
it's a bit manual um
[Music]
you wouldn't really want to do the
interactive stuff unless you're trying
to figure out how to do it so the
interactive builds that we just looked
at using running in the image the
container and then adding stuff manually
i tend to use that to
find out how to do something if i'm not
sure exactly
what the sequence of operations are to
do something i will do that to do a
trial run
the best way to do is to do an automated
build
now this is important here you need to
have a directory
of all the files contained
required for the build don't have a
directory with any rubbish in it there
because that can cause major problems as
i found out
a couple of days ago
so what you do is you create a directory
for each build a separate directory
then you create a file in that directory
called dockerfile with a capital d
and that doc
file defines the build process
and the directory
with the docker file is called the build
context
so every single command in the docker
file
generates a separate layer on top of the
image
and how it works is this
it takes the base image
it creates a container from the base
image
it executes the first command in the
docker file
it then saves the image as saves the
container as another image
then it starts that container that image
is another container then it executes
second command
then it saves the container as an image
and then runs the image as a container
and it's a continuous sequence so you
can end up with a lot of layers added
each line of the gear dockerfile can
create another layer in the image
there's a way round
around it to get the number of layers
reduced which we'll look at as well
a docker file it has to be called
dockerfile it's just a text file and the
first line should always be from and
that is the base image
the starting image which you'll get from
either the local
machine or from docker hub or wherever
else you want to specify to come from
optionally you can give a maintainer and
an email address
if you wish to do that if you wish to be
identified with the image
and then you add a number of commands
and we'll go through each of the
commands in turn they don't necessarily
appear in this order commands can be
entered in several ways
usually they can have the command
followed by just a simple string
or the command followed by a json array
whichever form you want to use
so the first one defines the default
shell i typically don't use this it must
be specified in adjacent form
so in this case we're doing
slash bin slash h minus c is the shell
which is going to be used to execute all
the other commands
right copy
when you
run the build you've got the context
directory with the docker file in it
every other file in that directory can
be copied into the
container as part of the build process
so these source files and directories
must be in the build context which is
the directory containing the docker file
so in this case i've got a file called
jdk something dot rpm the star is just a
wild card and what he's going to do is
copy that rpm image into the slash temp
directory on the container okay
so once it runs that line the container
will now have that
jdk.rpm file
in its um in its container
destination directories must end in a
slash and they don't have to exist it
will automatically do an mkdir on the
directory if it doesn't exist
add
copies files from the context or remote
url so you can specify a full url there
and that'll copy them into
the
container so in this case i'm copying
i'm adding apache maven something dot
tar dot he said into slash opt
now this is an interesting one and a bit
surprising
if it finds an archive such as a tar.gz
file
without asking it will automatically
unzip and unpack it
so what will happen is in slash opt
after that add command you get the
contents
of the apache maven dot target gsa file
not the dot gt file itself it's done
automatically
done a tatar zxf on the file to unpack
it
run is used to execute arbitrary
commands so any valid command within the
environment that you've got will work so
run yum install minus y which remember
must be the minus y as it doesn't ask
questions
run rpm minus i
on the rpm file that will unpack the rpm
file install it
second one i'm doing two commands
separated by a semicolon cd slash opt
and then creating a symbolic link from
the maven archive to the name maven
each of those run commands generates a
separate layer on the image
you can get around it
by in the unix world if you use the
double ampersand to combine commands
together
then you can get away with a single one
so you could go run yummy store minus y
which ampersand ampersand rpm minus i so
on so on am
to
produce a single layer from multiple
chemicals
and you'll see that a lot in docker
files
m enables you to set environment
variables in the target image
so they'll end up in the um etc profile
so that these environment variables are
available so she's setting the java home
and the path environment variables and
this will be the actual environment
variables present in the container
how does the second command work
run rpm
rpm it basically it
installs an rpm package
no i is install
yep
confusing interactive install yeah rpm
minus i so this is set in two
environment
variables command sets the default
application so that means that if you
just run the container
docker run container image name it will
automatically execute the shell
otherwise you go docker run image name
command name and then it'll run that
command which overrides this one okay
so typically you have one command cmd
option
typically at the end of every docker
file to specify what the entry point is
and that normally runs an application
and then to do the the actual build you
do docker build minus t now minus t is
for tag
and that specifies the name of the image
that it's going to build so this is
going to create an image called centos
java colon latest
in our local
on our local disk
then the dot at the end specifies the
directory which is the build context
so that can be either dot for the
current working directory or it can be
the name of an absolute directory or a
relative directory containing a docker
file
so that's basically the um the process
of building an image
so now we've got a
an example where we're going to use
docker to build an image which is going
to be an ssh server
we're going to have a lot of fun with
the secure shell over the next
few the next lessons because
we have some interesting issues
associated with keys
so if we have any problems later on it
is to do with keys but this is going to
build
a duck container
based on an image an alpine image then
it's going to install the ssh software
set up some keys and then you're going
to be able to run the container and
connect to it using the secure shell so
that's the exercise i think it maybe
takes about half an hour so
as the usual if you have any questions
or when you're done send a message to
all participants and
we'll
see where we get in about half an hour
this exercise you have a number of
things happen here the one thing is you
really do need to solve problems it is
very important because if you're going
to be devops you're going to have to
solve the problems yourself with nobody
to help you
it's always
always a typo copying and pasting
commands can be very problematic
especially if there's
something like smart quotes in there
but you've got the tools to do that what
you need to do if something fails if it
says you cannot start something it means
the file doesn't exist that means you
missed a step so if you say cannot stop
stat tilde slash
ssh
idrsa.public means you didn't do the ssh
keygen step on step two so it's very
important that you actually execute all
the commands exactly and it's actually
worth typing them in
to make sure that they're complete so if
something's i mean there are a couple of
typos in this in the instructions i do a
bit that
um
but
it is a matter of going through each
step if you can't connect to something
it means the server doesn't work so then
you do a lot um docker logs on the
server and find out what's going on
there so probably if you can't connect
to the server it's because of
in step
three in the contents of the file
there's a few cases there's where
there's a couple of smart quotes in the
run sss
key gen
sjk and in the command the smart quotes
if you copy and paste the smart quotes
it simply won't work
okay so it's tough to what what i would
do
is assume i haven't got time to to work
on this any further because we've got
quite a lot more to cover today but what
i would do is i'll fix all the typos in
this
in this document uh let's stay or early
tomorrow so you can try it again at some
stage okay
um i've got a note of all the things
that needs to be changed
but it's a matter of trying to solve the
problems yeah
great
yeah
docker build
but you're missing docker build
minus t label space dot that is that
space dot is very important okay it must
be a directory
yeah absolutely research and development
is great um
just check things out because
basically one of the most important
things
if you're going to be a devops
professional is you've got to be a
problem solver
and you're going to hit all sorts of
problems in the real world and they're
going to be difficult to solve you'll do
a google search you will not get a
sensible answer
and um it's a matter i spend most of my
time
trying to get stuff working
simply because the documentation for say
docker is absolutely appalling most of
it's just wrong it's out of date
and doesn't work
you do a google search and you just get
more problems it's a matter of doing
the um
speed as problem solve
no you don't need to add anything to the
commands of the docker file you just put
them in as they are with the there's a
few quotes that need to be changed but
otherwise the commands
yeah when it says add authorized keys it
means you're expecting to find a file
called authorized keys in the build
directory and in a previous step you
actually copied the public key from the
ssh directory to a file called
authorized keys that's where it came
from you don't have to add anything to
it it's just literally as it states in
the instructions yeah
okay great
it's a difficult business
it's it's tough and it's getting worse i
assure you that um i'm getting
increasingly worried about the internet
because
the signals and noise ratio of the
internet is getting much much worse so
if you want to find something
about um the private life of a celebrity
you've got it on you get it as google
search will give you all the information
all the gossip you need if you want to
find how to
do something in software you're going to
have a challenge because most people
don't know the documentation that's
there's going to be out of date or
missing or downright wrong
that's the biggest challenge you
actually face
the biggest challenge i face it's quite
interesting to work around it but
okay i've got to solve this problem and
it can take a long time
so um
but welcome to the real world it's um
this is just the way it is you know
so
but yeah typos are the worst and
the error messages from the systems tend
to be very bad don't they they're not
very helpful
something didn't work okay so what what
happened yeah that's exactly the problem
that the um
we're living in an increasingly
difficult world to operate so you need
to be
a good problem solver and have a good
way of around how do i solve a problem
like this you know
give us a try yeah by all means i know
we'll do this retry the exercises
tomorrow um
and just spend a little bit of time
thinking about okay you've got an error
what is it what caused that error
um
because that's where you need to be
ultimately spear devops because that's
what it's all about
so but it's fun because it's a challenge
you
you have to when you get the answer when
you get it working he said it's a good
feeling isn't it yeah great i've got
this working
okay and um
solve problems for other people which is
effectively what you're going to be
doing as well
it is true yeah absolutely true
absolutely true
i'm you already i don't know unless
you've already encountered this haven't
you it's um
it's a little frustrating sometimes
yeah
i've spent half a day
wasting my time trying to get something
working
it was a stupid little reason like there
was a missing quote or something like
that
but yeah
you'll get there i'm sure you'll get
there
that's a good challenge on the course in
it to solve the problems and i've
noticed it's good that some of you are
helping the others which is really great
because that's another part of it is you
help each other when you get a problem
some of you have solved it some of you
get a bit stuck it's the problem
it's all about the learning process
uh docker
you don't tend to have user interfaces
on docker because
user interfaces require a lot of code
and
how do you connect to it
okay what we are going to do is connect
our virtual machines the ones you've got
on the um google cloud platform
via vnc so you'll be able to collect
from a local client
but typically yeah keep it light
it's absolutely spot-on russian that's
absolutely right docker containers
should be very minimal
servers which don't do an awful lot you
don't want a graphical environment
there might be a web server inside there
and in many cases there will be because
most applications like um like jenkins
and even docker itself have got web
front ends to them or or restaurant ends
so you can access the containers via a
web interface
absolutely that's your spot on is to get
the job done it's not for ease of use
you've got to um
you're not going to get an easy life
you're not going to get a nice fancy
user interface in fact with google
platform i was talking to my friend
randy
well yesterday
and
the graphical user interface the the ui
keeps changing but the command line
tools don't so what he does is always
uses the command line tools and scripts
everything
and so it always works
okay the user interface is unreliable
and messy whereas the scripts always
work
okay
and
that's one thing when you're doing sort
of operations work and that's what i did
when i started doing um administration
working for a
mobile phone company
i spent most of my time for the first
few months writing scripts
so i could totally automate everything
expose 22 exposes port 22 which is the
port that sslh listens on
yes you have to be good at writing
things you need to be a good
scriptwriter yeah absolutely
absolutely you need to know your um
your linux commands and your bash
shell scripting well
otherwise your life's gonna be very
difficult you have to end up typing an
awful lot of stuff
because a lot of the commands are quite
long absolutely right
just a good learning exercise
what docker run minus peter
it goes it's docker run minus p number
caller number and it says basically it's
like
yeah
no the exposed 22 says exposed port 22
to the outside world the doc um docker
one minus p2022 colon22 says when you
run the container map port 22 on the
container to port 2022 on the local host
which means that you can access the
container via a local port
any suggestions how to learn shelf
scripting
quickly take a shell scripting course
it's quite complex
yeah
um because shell scripting is actually
more difficult than you think um the
shells like bash and the corn shell are
very complex and they've got a they're
actually a complete programming language
in their entire right you can do all
sorts of amazing things in the show if
you really know what you need to do
like for example you never need to use
um
ork
if you know the shell
a good point yeah install have a live
distribution available
in a virtual machine or on a separate
machine or something like that and just
play around with it
but um writing shell scripts is actually
quite hard
because
there's a quirk of the shell scripts
that
the presence or absence of a space can
make a big difference in whether the
script works or not
and it's that bad
okay
okay so let's
move on to the next bit
because we've got other things to come
so why do changes have to be made to
containers rather than images images are
read only containers have a written
layer contains current programs or all
of the above
minus p2022 changes the port number from
22 to 202.22
okay
we're getting getting some answers
so the correct answer is d all of the
above yeah that's what it's all about
guys
working together help each other because
um
everybody will trip up over a step and
it'll be not obvious why
yeah make sure you've gotten a typos in
things and typos are not easy to spot
until you get changed i mean like i've
been in the training business a long
time and i'm very good at spotting silly
little typos which can keep people
puzzled for
hours um
but you that's something you need to
acquire as the time goes on the ability
to spot those little things like that
missing double quote or
that double quotes a smart quote
but it's all good you get there
so
registries and repositories
okay so let's have a look at this these
are the
important things about some
query store images so basically where do
you get the images from and how do you
get them in the right version
okay
and so
docker uses registries for doing this
and registers can exist in various
places they can be hosted by various
organizations or you can create your own
if you wish
and you need to think about where it
needs to be in security who needs to
access your images
so a register is a very strange name
a registry is basically a server
typically a web server
where images are stored
and every image has got a name
so
the registry balanced by docker is
stored in repositories now a repository
is something a little odd a repository
is a collection of images of different
versions so
you've got the registry called docker
hub
then you've got say the
the repository called alpine and in in
the repository called alpine are all the
versions of the alpine images that
docker hub supports
okay so remember a repository is a
collection of images of different
versions usually including latest
and the tag despite describes exactly
what the image is so the tag is the name
of the image if you like
so actually when you talk about an image
it's actually got a several different
names
so if we talk about nginx which is a web
server
you can go
docker pool nginx that'll give you
docker
nginx colon latest
you go docker pool
ngix
colon 1.9 will get you 1.9
you can also go
docker pool hub.docker.com
underscore nginx colon 1.9 that gives
you the same thing
basically it defaults to docker
hub.docker.com
underscore slash followed by the name
because docker hub is the default
so you can see that the full name of it
is actually um
a domain name a url followed by a path
name followed by the actual registry
so the labels
which are the full names of the images
are
basically your eyes they look like
them they really are
so it consists of a fully fully
qualified domain name of the registry
which defaults to docker hub
the namespace which is underscore for
docker hub an r for user anybody else
then the repository name which is really
the image name okay
uh also you could also add the
organization name then you have the
repository name which is the actual
image name and then you have the version
number afterwards
so we've got the url looks like that
we've got
docker dot com slash r for repository
slash database is the name of the user
or organization
netclernal dash sc is the name of the
image and then after that you can go
colon version number if you wish
so docker hub isn't the only one does
they do google container registry part
of the
google container platform
amazon has got one for um aws this um
key it's got free ones and you can also
set up your own private ones as well
now a lot of these varieties like
automated builds so what happens is this
you set up an account with
docker hub say
you also set up an account which say
github the git repository for source
control
then you connect them together
then what happens is
every time you make a commit your get
repository will contain a docker file on
any other file
every time you commit to the git
repository
docker hub will check out
that check that commit
and generate a new image by using a
docker build
and this is the preferred solution
and actually you may need to do it that
way so it's an automated process
you commit the docker file it builds an
image for you you don't have to build
the image and upload it
so to set up a repository you need to
have a user account with like a hub need
to log in create a repository
give it a name and all that sort of
stuff a name space and everything
set its visibility and create it
and then you can
put the
docker file in there and everything
works like fine
to log into the registry you do a lock
docker login and specify your username
and that will log you into the um
the docker hub account it'll store your
username and password in a file in your
home directory called docker slash
config.json
so the images need to be the same name
as the repository
and so what you can do there is you can
create
an image from
us your name you can commit the image
and give it a name what you have to do
there is basically
the name of the image must be the
repository name slash
the image name
and so you must make sure that the image
name matches which is the tag matches
the name of the repository so if you get
created a positive with a certain name
then you must make sure that you rename
it
by doing a commit or a tag operation
you can re-type the image to make it
have another name
you'll see how this works in detail
later on and then you pull it using the
full name so that's effectively pulling
something from docker hub
it's got an
dot implicit
slash r slash then it's the
username followed by the image name
column possibly version number and this
is the thing the version number the
version number
can be more than just a number
in this case i've got an image called
question
and the label is java dash 1.0
so it's not unusual to have say
i've got say an image called alpine and
i'm going to call the the image
alpine colon ssh which is alpine plus
ssh and you'll find that location is
used quite a lot
on docker hub as well
you can delete images by giving them the
full name just as you can before
private registries
are if you want to
store images you don't want to put them
in docker hub or somewhere else
you might have to pay for them or you
want to keep them local
you might want to keep them secret
deal with things for
various project life cycles so you want
if you want to have a private registry
you can do that
there's several ways of doing that there
is a docker container called registry
which contains the docker registry if
you do have a pool registry you'll get
yourself a docker container containing
all the code to implement the docker
registry
and then what you can do is run that
registry as a container
and we're using the minus p option here
to map
a container port to a host port this is
a key aspect of networking in docker
the um the actual container is listing
on port 5000 here
on its local network which you can't get
to from the host
if you do the minus p
it creates a port on the host which is
mapped to the port 5000 on the internal
network that docker maintains
that's how you expose containers to the
outside world
by effectively making them listed on
ports on the local host itself so using
the ip address of the host you can get
to the container via the port number
so once that's done
you specify the registry as the host
name colon 5000 in this case localhost
and so now what we can do is we can pull
an image called alpine which is going to
give you the alpine from the docker hub
the tag re basically creates a new image
with a different name
so we're calling alpine cola latest
local host column 5000 slash alpine
colon latex which means that this image
now belongs to that new registry on
local host colon 5000
then you can push that image onto the
local registry that's how it works so
remember the registry name is part of
the label
unless it's on docker hub when it's by
default
now if you want to configure the
registry which you normally need to do
it's configured by a yml file which are
always wonderful
what you can do is override the
configuration file by putting a
config.yml
into a directory what that minus v
switch is doing there is it's mounting
a local directory a local file called
slash data slash config.yml
onto slash accessory slash docker slash
registry slash config.yml
and that means it'll use that
configuration file
to
just configure the registry because that
file will override the existing
config.yml file in the default
image so external configuration is
always required uh typically you need to
have external storage because if you
delete the container you lose all the
images we'll look at docker volumes
later
but um the configuration files are quite
complex and there are sample
configuration files in the docker git
repository
there's also an rpm package available
for
red hat
linux like enterprise linux fedora and
centos
and if you install the rpm package
it will implement a registry in a
container
or a host machine
and it uses a python program called
unicorn green unicorn which is a
python-based http server which gives you
basically a web server functionality
because
the registries are actually basically
web servers with the images underneath
them
so if you want to install
a registry on a standalone computer
rather than the container you just
install the docker registry package onto
your
red hat based
linux machine
and then you change the registry.yml
file to configure it then you restart
the registry and that's it you've got
yourself a docker registry on a local
machine
if you want to do in a container it's
slightly more complex because you
haven't got any boot scripts
so what you need to do is write a shell
script which starts up the g unicorn web
server and configures it with the
registry so basically this rather messy
looking script
will enable you to run
the rpm package based
in a container if you want to do that
so to do it in dot container you pull a
rpm
uh image that is sent to us
you add the
rpm using either docker file or manually
and then you
change the configuration file replace it
or edit it
and then you install the bootscript that
complicated thing in a suitable place
and then create the new image from that
and then you've got yourself
a registry image in a docker container
then just run the container
it's always a good idea when you build a
container and it will start an image to
run it as a container with the bin slash
bash
to start with so you can check
everything's okay
and then
once that's all up and running you start
it up this is actually starting the
basically manually
and then you can try doing this like a
search on the container trying pushing
an image on the container and checking
that the image is actually in the
container
okay so that's the docker registries
so now we've got a
an exercise to do this pull the centos
image
start the container install the registry
and run the registry and put and push an
image into it
so now we're going to need a url
for doing this
this is the
url
okay and so we'll probably be about half
an hour on this so um
let's do the same thing get tell me when
you're done any problems
post it and try and help each other out
try and solve some problems because it's
it's a tricky business okay i'll speak
to you soon
okay so that was a much more
straightforward one this interesting
thing about copy paste um
the problem is
that
certain
word processing tools like word and
powerpoint and the other ones in
microsoft
what they do is they replace certain
characters with strange characters that
don't really exist in the i.t world in
terms of unix
the classic ones are the smart quotes
where instead of having double quotes
which are just both the same you have
the kind of sixes and nines
and also if you type minus minus in any
microsoft product it turns into this
horrible long vertical bar thing
which is not a valid code
in ascii and will not work under any
circumstances in unix
and what happens is you use these tools
and
those codes get copied and pasted into
your
application and the codes actually do
are valid
characters but the unit's command
doesn't understand them that's the
problem it is a big problem actually
it really annoys me that um
using sort of like powerpoint i type
minus minus and i get this stupid long
bar thing
in fact i've actually now
with them in conjunction with a
colleague we've decided that we're not
going to use microsoft products anymore
for any documentation we're going to use
latex
which is a very old program but it
actually does do it properly and we're
not going to use powerpoint we're going
to use latex for her presentations
because it doesn't do those stupid
things to the characters
so yeah in the
some of the instructions we've got smart
quotes and we've got these from the city
minus sign characters which don't work
so there's nothing
you can't really beat some kind of um
doing things badly
um no it's not really
a font issue it's actually that
by default the microsoft projects like
uh powerpoint and word
have these autocorrect facilities unless
you switch them off hard
they will try and convert certain things
so that if you use a
single quote it likes to use the back
tick in the front tick if you use a
double quote you'd like to use the sixes
and nine characters
uh nano's just another editor no vi you
can guarantee is always going to be
there
if you're going to if you're going to
use unix
which you probably almost certainly will
be
you really need to know vi
you don't need to know every single
command you can you can learn one new
command every week for the rest of your
life maybe but as long as you know the
basics you'll be fine but vi is just the
the standard text editor in the unix
world and you can guarantee it's gonna
be there nano is another one
which may or may not be there depending
on the distribution you've got
so in terms of text editors yeah
vi is the one unfortunately but there's
some great vi uh cheat sheets you can
download and print out which tell you
what the basic commands are but you can
actually use vi in a very simplistic way
all you need to know is the insert and
command mode and then just use the arrow
keys and delete
and type
okay so that's some docker registry
where we created a register there
so we have now the knowledge check for
this one
how can you tell which repository an
image comes from
okay you have a number of answers there
oh quite a few different answers there
well the answer is a the repository
location is contained in the image label
and if there isn't an image label it
defaults to docker hub
okay so
there's a very short section here on
docker machine which is used for
managing remote docker instances
so what is docker machine
it's a management tool
for
dealing with docker hosts so the idea is
that you've got a network of machines
which may be local or on the cloud
and use it to administer them what you
do is you designate one particular
machine
one compute computer which is the
management machine and you install
docker machine on it
you can also
install docker daemon and client on the
same machine if you want
it's entirely up to you
but it was only available online
for early versions but um
now it's available on other systems such
as um
os x and windows
so what it does is it controls other
hosts and enables you to install
and maintain docker on other machines
it's a great idea
you just have a central location where
you deal with that
so
what do you use it for
well one thing is to run docker install
docker on remote hosts
you can actually use it in conjunction
with the docker toolbox on virtual
machines as well in fact the original
versions of osx and windows
required docker machine because if what
you did was you ran the docker demon in
a virtual machine and you need to be
able to administer it and you could only
do that from the local machine by using
docker
docker machine itself as the as a tool
so docker has components docker itself
is really docker engine it's the docker
daemon which has a restful api and the
command line client that's basically
that part there's also
a machine
which is
itself a separate executable
it may come with
the the actual docker install it might
be separate
some of these components are actually
separate downloads
the docker machine has its own command
line client called docker machine
if you install that it also has a docker
client
so you may need to install it separately
or it may come with your docker
installation
there is actually another one called
duck compose which is really bizarre for
most
distributions of even linux you have to
download the binary
independently of everything else which
is rather odd
so docker machine has the means where
you can create a docker
installation on a remote machine
which is a rather interesting concept
it's not perfect by a long way i had a
few problems but um it does actually
work in principle
so what it does is allows you to install
docker on a remote machine
first of all you need to set up a few
things
and first the first thing you need to
think about is security now se linux
um yeah
se linux is security enhanced linux
which is an extension to linux
which was instigated by the nsa in the
usa
security organization
the reason for it being is that
in the units world route is all-powerful
and that was considered bad from the
security perspective so what they did
was they installed the sc linux which
changes the way the rules work so
basically root isn't all powerful
anymore because the sqlites can stop
anybody from doing anything
but it can have some very strange
effects
i had an ex experience
a while ago
where i installed linux on a bunch of
machines and wanted to exchange mail
messages
and we couldn't send mail messages why
not
i looked at everything all the servers
were running on port 25 they were
listening on the external ip address and
yet we couldn't send mail messages
fc linux blocked it so the first thing
to do is switch xt linux off
and you can do that by changing the file
sd line it says exceptions as you like
slash config
and said sd likes to disable and reboot
and then select goes away forever
but also make sure
that there are no firewall walls
blocking the ports by default many linux
installations have firewall rules on the
input chain
which block external access to certain
port numbers you may need to switch
those off otherwise it's not going to
work
you also need to have
sudo access
on the remote machine without password
it looks sounding a bit like a security
nightmare isn't it we switch off the se
linux which is a security system
we switch off password protected sudo
access to root on the remote machine
it's not looking good but we have to do
it so what you need to do
is edit the et cetera sudo as file
and grants
no password access to
maybe a single user which is the one
that you're going to use for docker not
everybody in this case in this case i'll
make it a bit more restricted
and then what you need to do is have ssh
access with no password another security
interest issue hmm getting a bit worried
about security here and this is not the
worst of it
so what you need to do is first of all
generate
a pair of keys which you just actually
in an earlier exercise ssh key gen minus
trsa
generates public private key pair
and what you need to do is copy the
public key from the local machine
to the and append it to the authorized
keys on the remote machine
the authorized keys
file in the ssh directory on the remote
machine contains a list of public keys
of
users on remote hosts who are allowed to
connect without a password
then what you do is you copy the key
to the remote host append it to the
authorized key files and then you've got
complete access
and then you can install docker remotely
this enables you to access a machine
which has already got docker installed
where what you specify is the machine's
ip address and the name
and basically docker machine needs to be
able to manage all remote machines so it
needs to be told about them you either
do it by create where you tell it about
an existing one
or you do a create with a different set
of parameters where it actually creates
a docker instance on the machine
and then you can do a docker machine ls
on your docker machine
machine the one that manages everything
do a docker machine ls and it'll list
all the remote machines it knows about
all the machines it can manage
it needs a number of drivers
this one's for the various cloud ones
like aws and google cloud platform
and they allow various things to be
started and stopped and it's very
powerful stuff there so you've got the
aws amazon
ec2 and the gce one for google so you've
got the docker machine drivers enable
you to install machines
remotely
now there are some issues
so for example with centos
i use docker machine to install
docker on centos another boot script
missing
a rather important one which was the one
that did the port listening
so i had to manually add it
before i did the install to make it work
so it's not perfect the support of
docker for other for certain flavors of
linux is not complete
they seem to favor ubuntu linux for some
reason which i really don't understand i
personally detest ubuntu because it's um
it's based on um
deviant which is actually a very good
distribution but they've done some
horrible things
to debian and ubuntu got a popularity
which i really don't understand because
if you go into the covers of ubuntu it's
absolutely appalling the boot system is
completely messed up
that's my personal opinion but um i
think
if they have made a complete mess of
ubuntu
so that's the knowledge down honest
deny check for this
so what security issues can affect
docker machine operation
yeah a b and d work yeah it's um it can
be blocked by sc linux and firewall
rules
um
it does require password free ssh and
pseudo access
so there's
two things a little bit concerning in
the security sense of the world but
actually it is d a and or b above
okay
so key takeaways
virtualization is a great thing it
enables you to have different computing
environments
which are separated and isolated from
each other rather than to have to
deal with all the dependency problems
and issues
the linux kernel has been enhanced in
wonderful ways to enable container
virtualization to happen
docker is a very powerful tool it's got
the concepts of images and containers
it's not the only one you can also use
lxd and a rocket
docker image is constructed by adding
layers to a base image it's always image
container image container image that
kind of structure
registries manage repositories of images
remember a repository is just
different versions of the same image
it's a little confusing because
repositories mean something different in
the context of safe source control where
a repository applies to an entire
project
and docker machine allows docker to be
installed and managed on remote machines
so now we have the quiz so quiz one what
is docker engine
okay this is looking
looking good
it's see it's the daemon the client and
the restful api
it's just referred to as docker or the
demon or the client
but it's basically the basic core stuff
that works
so what is docker machine
okay shouldn't have consecutive answers
with the same answer should i really
it's um
it gets a little confusing but yeah it's
c it's software to remotely install and
manage docker installations
so quick c what is container
virtualization
okay it's a
the
operating system
level virtualization which a standalone
application is controlled by a single
kernel
so what is the union file system quiz
for
okay
yep it's the file system which can be
assembled in layers it's very important
for the
concept behind this containerization and
quiz five where is the docker registry
some different answers there
it's b it's a service emerging repo
remote repositories and images okay
so that's the end of this section on
virtualization lightweight containers
the next lesson which is going to be
next saturday is on data storage in
access so we're going to look at various
types of databases and big data and the
importance of data
so
a couple of things to go for the
oops we're going to go back
so
i think we learned a lot today um
i think as we see getting things to work
is actually quite difficult and
i think that one of the biggest
challenges for devops i think as we've
seen today
and yesterday in fact is that many of
the tools are quite hard to configure
and you have to do it command line you
don't have fancy gui's
and you need to solve problems so that's
one of the biggest challenges when we
talk about the cultural changes in deuts
so um
we've got a break of a week i
strongly recommend if you if you've got
time to just work through some of these
things and do some research
try and
make sure you understand things
completely because it gets
we're going to go build on what we've
done over the next um few weeks until we
get to lesson eight so it's all good
stuff
but so now question answer have you got
any questions
found anything from today
yesterday future
or in general
yeah the exposed keyword is actually not
necessary
when you do the docker run command you
go minus p
local port colon
remote uh
container port
so um yeah
you don't have to do the expose command
it's not necessary
it was probably was there but it not
necessary
any other questions
yeah a good question the the slides are
online if you go to the lms
on the simply loan website you have the
login for that
uh if you remember the very first
presentation done by the the host
she pointed that out
so
you've got the ebook which is basically
the slides
you've got the urls for the um
the courses um
just basically
to get to the you've got the urls yet
and you just try them out rework things
try a few of the commands
look at some of the
other things that you can extend
okay
the videos from the webex session
from today will be available
in 24 hours i believe the ones from
yesterday should be available now
if you want to access them
uh windows can the windows client be put
on docker
um you can install docker on windows if
you've got the right version or if you
use the docker toolkit
i think there are some windows images
you can actually windows images you can
use
problem with windows is it's all
licensed and
the other way what you mean
okay
putting windows in docker i'm not sure
you can do that
it doesn't make really make any sense
because what happens is docker images
are actually
just partial file systems they're not
operating systems
okay you've got the support people if
you want to contact them
um say in the in the break which is the
week between now and saturday
if you can practice anything you don't
quite understand or have problems with
why don't you do so
now if you want to
start a an ubuntu container and access
it from put to putty putty is basically
ssh
so if you do the exercise where we
installed the ssh
server
or you're using ubuntu container make
sure the ssh server is running then you
can access it from putty because party
is just an ssh client
all the apps available as images on
docker hub massive amount just go to
dockerhub.org
and um just just scan it
it'll show you everything that's
available and there's a huge number of
images
um every single
popular flavor of linux with all sorts
of combinations of things installed on
it
so yeah i mean if you want jenkins there
there's jenkins if you want some
a web server there's apache there's
nginx there's all sorts of stuff there
so do play around with it pull the
images down and try them out a lot of
the images in docker hub
work in two ways that they basically
pull the image and there's usually
documentation associated with them
if you read the documentation you'll
find that you can set certain options on
the command line when you run the
container which configure it
and you can do some really good stuff so
basically
um images are more complex than it
appears it's not just build the image
run the image it's actually build the
image
then it runs a script which enables you
to configure the image and then run the
image so it's quite complex
okay so make the use let's use the break
um there is the help and support
the evaluation form will appear when you
check out and thank you very much for
attending today and
look forward to
the next session next saturday
the usual time
thank you
um
you